iran's provocations escalate democrats
compete for attention and yes I will
indeed review Game of Thrones I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
it's a spoiler alert bran what the f
okay well later on and they try don't
want to talk politics I just went to an
hour on that final Game of Thrones
episode so later in the show we will do
a full hour on that Game of Thrones
final episode but first we're never
gonna agree on everything I think we can
all agree that brand should not have
been King but I think we can all agree
on something else too we could all use
more sleep getting a great night's sleep
is easier and more affordable than you
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you just need
to change your sheets that's why you
should check out bowl and branch
everything bowl and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means they
start out super soft they get even
softer over time you buy it directly
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets those can
cost up to a thousand bucks in the store
but Boleyn brand sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks everyone who
tries Bowl and bran sheets loves them
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund I don't think you're
gonna want to send them back because
they are indeed awesome my wife and I
have bowling bran sheets we actually
threw out all of our other sheets
because once you've tried them it kind
of ruin other sheets for you they're
that good there's no risk and no reason
not to give them a try to get you
started right now my listeners can get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch comm promo code Ben that
is bull and branch calm today bull and
branch calm for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets that's bol and branch calm
promo code Ben oh and branch calm promo
code Ben go check them out right now
okay so over the weekend the Iranians
continued to escalate the situation in
the Middle East they obviously would
like a conflict so President Trump does
not want a conflict the Trump
administration does not want a conflict
despite all of the talk from the left
about john bolton itching for conflict
with the iranians we are now in year
three of the trump administration he
does not want a conflict with iran who
would like to see the regime fall you'd
like to see it fall from the inside and
that involves containment and yes the
credible threat of military force to
prevent Iran from getting too aggressive
but it's pretty obvious that Trump
doesn't want war
Trump is by nature more of an
isolationist on foreign policy he does
not like being involved in different
areas of the world nonetheless President
Trump threatened around with destruction
as tensions flared after a rocket almost
hit the US
in Baghdad according to the Sun in the
UK apparently a rocket landed less than
a mile from the US Embassy in Baghdad
Green Zone further stoking hostility in
the region tensions between the United
States and Iran have escalated in recent
weeks after American warships and
bombers were ordered to the Middle East
to counter an unexplained threat the US
Embassy in Baghdad and its consulate in
the northern city of Erbil evacuated
non-essential staff this week following
the escalating tensions with Iran Trump
has also tightened economic sanctions
originally a brigadier general in the
British Army said that he did not see
the reason why the United States was
getting uptight with Iran and then it
turns out that the Secretary of State
over the Foreign Secretary rather in
Britain came forward and said no the
info is pretty good Iran is getting a
lot more militant so president Trump
tweeted out in his own inimitable
fashion quote if Iran wants to fade that
would be the official end Iran never
threatened the United States again
exclamation point now I appreciate the
sentiment I really do I also will note
the President Trump used exactly the
same sort of language with regard to
North Korea before he then had as much
ballyhooed summit with kim jeong-hoon
which resulted in approximately nothing
it resulted in the North Koreans
continuing to develop their technology
it resulted in the North Koreans being
elevated on the world stage so taking
president Trump's twitter account at
face value is always a mistake president
from fulminates on his Twitter account
he says bloviating things on his Twitter
account I think would be good if the
Iranian regime understands that if they
cross the line we will end them and the
truth is we would end them they could do
us damage because they have terrorist
cells all around the world they could do
us damage because there are American
allies within striking distance of
Iranian missiles but if they were to go
to full-scale war with the United States
that war lasts not particularly long
because the fact is the US military is
the greatest fighting force ever
assembled in the history of mankind and
Iran is a second-rate military force
despite the large size of the Iran
Revolutionary Guard Corps nonetheless it
is obvious that President Trump does not
want war with Iran general david
petraeus
who's not exactly a friend of the
administration he came out on ABC this
week he said um no Trump is not
interested in war and this is obviously
true frankly it's pretty clear that he
doesn't want to go to war with Iran he's
not after regime change he's after what
Secretary Pompeyo
announced as the objective which is
regime behavior change Iran is a country
that has a population that is three
times the size of Iraq when we invaded
it and a landmass that is three to four
times the size of Iraq as well and I
think any thoughts about invading Iran
again rightly the president has shelved
those I think
okay so Petraeus is of course correct
about this now the way the media are
treating this is that Trump is right on
the verge of launching war in Iran
there's give me a wag the dog scenario
yeah except Trump hasn't built any
support for that look at the poll
numbers this would not be a popular move
there's nobody on the right who's in
favor of a war with Iran at this point
legitimately no one yeah John Bolton is
not in favor of war with Iran I don't
know a single person in conservative
circles who's interested in war with
Iran at this point including the most
quote-unquote neocon forces inside the
conservative movement so I don't know
where this narrative is coming from that
Trump is desperate for a war with Iran
in reality Iran is desperate for some
sort of military conflict short of
complete war with the United States
because they're trying to shore up their
flailing economy they're trying to
create a rally round the flag effect in
Iran there have been running protests
for months there thanks to economic
shortages that's been largely ignored by
the world media mainly because the media
do not have great access to what is
going on in Iran but the media in the
West are creating this narrative that
Trump is desperate for war that Trump is
trying to do a george w bush circa 2003
with regard to iraq again there is no
evidence of that whatsoever now
meanwhile over the weekend a lot of
controversy broke out because Justin
Amash who is a congress person from
Michigan Republican Congress person very
libertarian he's been a guest on our
radio show Justin Amash tweeted this out
over the weekend quote here are my
principled conclusions this is after
reading the Imola report one attorney
general bar has deliberately
misrepresented Muller's report now again
I don't think there's any evidence for
that at all I'm gonna analyze these one
by one I don't think there's any
evidence for this at all that bar has
deliberately mess from misrepresented
Muller's report we can all see the
report bar gave the bottom line
conclusions in the Moller report
Muller's people themselves acknowledged
that those conclusions were accurate
they just didn't like the
characterization they thought that bar
should have originally laid out all of
the evidence in his orig
in a letter when bar basically just said
look my job as Attorney General is not
to make a case against somebody we are
not prosecuting my job as the Attorney
General is to say whether or not the
person is being prosecuted Justin Amash
also claimed that President Trump has
engaged in an impeachable conduct he
then does not name what exactly the
impeachable conduct is now here's the
truth about impeachment impeachment is
of course a political standard it is not
in fact a legal standard so you can
impeach anybody for virtually any reason
high crimes and misdemeanors does not
have any legal definition in in other
words if Congress were to impeach the
president he can't then appeal to the
Supreme Court and say well Congress
deliberately misinterpreted high crimes
and misdemeanors the impeachment is no
good Congress can do whatever it wants
right there so numbers one and two he
has four points that he makes in this
tweet that got all sorts of attention
because he's a Republican saying that
Trump is impeachable so point number one
that he makes is that barred
deliberately misrepresented molars
report I see no evidence of this point
number two
Trump has engaged in impeachable conduct
well it depends on your definition of
impeachable conduct I suppose but I
don't see anything that he did that is
quote-unquote impeachable I see stuff
that's bad I see the president Trump did
stuff that is embarrassing for him I see
the president from fulminates in a way
that his unbeli office but is that
impeachable he didn't commit obstruction
of justice
according to Muller himself he didn't
actually engage in any collusion with
the Russians so what exactly is
impeachable as opposed to just
embarrassing bad conduct three this is
on Russia's third point partisanship has
eroded our system of checks and balances
well that part is obviously true but
that's been true for a very long time
mean Eric Holder was acting in his own
words as President Obama's wingman so
that is nothing new partisanship has of
course eroded our system of checks and
balances Congress no longer holds the
President to account if he's a member of
their own party and if the president is
not a member of their own party then
people are interested in endless
investigations even if those
investigations results in nothing and
finally Amash says few members of
Congress have read the report that
obviously is true as well the media ran
with this because Amash is of course a
libertarian leaning Republican in
Michigan he's in a very tightly
contested race in Michigan he's the most
likely Republican to be ousted in the
primary at this point as a general rule
I really like Justin Amash
representative Amash his perspective on
the role of government I think is quite
correct he and I have similar views on
on the role of government in the
libertarian nature of government with
that said Amash I think is off base here
he then completes his tweets by
suggesting contrary to bars portrayal
mothers report reveals the president
Trump engaged in specific actions and a
pattern of behavior that meet the
threshold for impeachment but that's not
what Bar ruled right Barr didn't say
anything about impeachment Barr just
said that there is nothing that is
criminally prosecute about bars letter
and his statements go to that the AG's
job is not to determine whether
something is impeachable or not that's
Congress has dropped well the press have
had a field day with Amash as tweets
Politico ran a long article about the
bravery of Justin Amash for coming out
and saying this again if I thought that
Amash were correct I would think that
it's brave it's certainly brave to the
extent that he's running against the
prevailing winds inside his own party
but brave is not the same thing as as
correct and in this particular case I
don't see that he is exactly correct
here according to Politico in recent
days more rank-and-file Democrats have
said they support initiating impeachment
proceedings against the president
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and most Democratic
leaders and committee chairs have
resisted those calls setting their
ongoing investigations into the
president's alleged conduct House
Judiciary Committee for example is
investigating Trump for allegations of
obstruction of justice and abuses of
power now that is the most telling thing
the Democrats are really not all that
interested in impeaching President Trump
because they don't believe they have
solid enough grounds with the American
public to push for impeachment they are
afraid of the backlash should that
happen so when Amash says that Trump has
engaged in impeachable conduct the
Democrats don't think so the Democrats
don't think so and because the Democrats
don't think so it's interesting that
Amash is arguing that extreme
partisanship is undercutting the case
for impeachment I think that if extreme
partisanship were to cut in favor of
anything it would cut in favor of
impeachment in a statement on Saturday
Republican National Committee chairwoman
Rhonda McDaniel slammed Amash for quote
parroting the Democrats talking points
on Russia McDaniel didn't explicitly
endorse a GOP primary challenge to Amash
in 2020 but noted that voters in a
mashes district strongly support this
president now Amash does have a rival
who is running in the primary and is
campaigning in front of giant Trump
Flags so it's pretty obvious this person
knows where his brain
is buttered with regard to the
Republican base president Trump himself
fired back on the marsh I'll get to that
in just one second first it is spring
the time of year when seeds grow into
flowers and you grow up financially at
least your family needs protection if
something should happen to you that
means you need life insurance thankfully
policies genius makes it easy to get
that financial security without the
growing pains policy genius is the easy
way to buy life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
top insurers and find your best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape no Commission's no hidden fees
just financial protection and peace of
mind no strings attached policy genius
doesn't just do life insurance they also
make it easy to compare and buy home
insurance auto insurance disability
insurance so the next time you stop to
smell the roses pull out that phone head
on over to policy genius com policy
genius spring is here kick it off by
nipping life insurance in the body be a
responsible adult I know it's a part of
adulting they've turned it into a verb a
part of adulting is ensuring that you
have taken care of your family if god
forbid something should happen you I
know it's depressing to think about once
you get that life insurance taken care
of you don't have to worry about it
again at least at least your death won't
destroy your family financially if you
got life insurance go check them out
right now policy genius and they have
all sorts of insurance in other areas as
well policy genius.com go check them out
right now so President Trump
lashed back at Hamas via Twitter he said
never a fan of Justin Amash a total
lightweight who opposes me and some of
our great Republican ideas and policies
just for the sake of getting his name
out there through controversy if he
actually read the biased mullah report
composed by 18 angry Dems who hated
Trump he would see it was nevertheless
strong and no collusion and ultimately
no obstruction anyway how do you
obstruct when there's no crime and in
fact the crimes were committed by the
other side Justin is a loser who sadly
plays right into our opponents hands so
obviously President Trump is taking it
personally when President Trump uses a
couple of key terms you know he's taking
it personally lightweight and loser when
you call someone a lightweight that
means the president is taking it
personally and by the way I don't blame
the president for taking it personally
so I think it's good strategy to attack
amah sure no should I say Justin Amash
is entitled to his opinion obviously I
think he's miss reading the report and
then if you want to encourage a primary
challenge you quietly do that
nonetheless
fact that Trump is angry about this
President Trump is feeling the pressure
there's just no question that President
Trump is feeling the pressure and it's
not helping that there are people like
Mitt Romney Romney is out there saying
emotions brave he disagrees with Amash
but Amash is brave a statement with
which I generally agree but there's a
general perception that Romney himself
is much more comfortable attacking
people on the right than people on the
left here is Mitt Romney basically quasi
supporting Amash here my own view is
that Justin Amash has reached a
different conclusion that I have I
respect him I think it's a courageous
statement but I believe that to make a
case for obstruction of justice you just
don't have the elements that are
evidenced in this document and I also
believe that an impeachment call is not
only something that relates to the law
but also considers practicality and
politics and the American people just
aren't there and I think those that are
considering impeach might have to look
also at the jury which would be the
Senate the Senate is certainly not there
either
okay Romney is right about all of the
last part of it the problem is that the
people who are expressing sympathy for
Amash as a general rule our people who
the Republican base does not trust in
Mitt Romney is one of those people
unfortunately okay in just a second
we're going to get to the real reason
the president Trump is I think on edge
and the real reason he is on edge is
because the president is running a very
tough reelect race the fact is the polls
are not cutting in his favor in places
like Michigan and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin president Trump has solidified
Ohio he is not solidified Florida if the
economy goes south at all not only does
the president lose reelection the
president loses reelection pretty
handily I mean I hate to be the bearer
of bad tidings here but the fact is that
the polls are just not good for the
president at this point he has to bet on
the Democrats destroying themselves and
this is why most Democrats at this point
or at least a plurality of Democrats are
looking to Joe Biden the reason they're
looking to Biden is because they think
that Biden is moderate enough to win a
state like Florida and take Pennsylvania
away from Trump and take Wisconsin away
from Trump and take Michigan away from
Trump and by the way that is what the
polls show at this point in time now
listen we're a year and a half out a lot
can happen Joe Biden could fall apart at
the seams he has before in presidential
races and the fact is that the
Democratic Party is increasingly a rat
party representative Amelia Chaya Paul
and she came out over the weekend and
she described the Democratic Party and
the fact is that the Democratic Party's
policies are well to the left of
mainstream America I think the party's
response is gonna be strong and I
hopefully you've seen that it's strong
across the board I know personally I do
think that there should be a set of core
democratic ideals that we all agree to
and that you can't say you're a Democrat
if you're against immigrants if you're
against abortion if you're against gay
marriage and LGBTQ rights I'm not sure
what it means to be a Democrat if if all
of those things are true okay so
basically jayapala who's a congresswoman
from Washington all Democrats are Pro
illegal immigration all of them are
pro-abortion all of them are pro gay
marriage all of them are Pro LGBT rights
which I assume would include the
so-called the quality Act which has
passed the Democratic House and is an
act so radical that many advocates of
things like same-sex marriage are still
looking at this and saying this violates
core constitutional freedoms it
basically forces everyone in the country
who is religious to knuckle under to the
social left the democratic program is
well to the left of the general public
so the Democrats instead are seeking to
present the most palatable face and that
really looks like Joe Biden right now
because Joe Biden is widely considered
the not only most known Democrat but
also the guy that most Americans are
kind of comfortable with it's hard to
find a lot of Americans who have
tremendous amounts of ire or disdain for
Joe Biden at worst they think that he's
kind of a dunderhead but they're not a
lot of Republicans who are motivated by
Joe Biden to go out there in the same
way that they were motivated by Hillary
Clinton who they saw as a really
nefarious character Biden thus he's
making a pretty generic Democratic
argument for why he ought to be
president right now he's fibbing all the
while doing it he is in fact a demagogue
I mean this is a guy who again back in
2012 suggested that black people were
gonna be put back and changed by Mitt
Romney of all humans but over the
weekend he was out there campaigning and
he's doing the moderate thing he says
listen we don't need to be angry our
politics is too angry I will remind you
that last week at a rally a woman got up
and said to him that she believes that
Donald Trump stole the election and
effectively was a tool of Russia and
Biden said maybe you should be my
running mate so much for no anger in
politics here's Joe Biden doing that
routine though folks say Democrats
want to hear about unity they say
Democrats are so angry that the anger
candidate can be the better chance he or
she has to win the Democratic nomination
well I don't believe it I really don't
the Democrats I believe Democrats want
to unify this nation that's what our
party's always been about if the
American people want a president to add
to our division lead with a clenched
fist a closed hand a hard heart to
demonize your opponents who spew hatred
they don't need me
they've got President Donald Trump okay
well the fact is that Barack Obama did
run with a closed fist in a hard heart
he was quite cruel to his political
opponents throughout his presidency he
was constantly suggesting that his
political opponents were motivated by
racism and greed Joe Biden did a lot of
the same sort of stuff nonetheless this
is the face that Democrats are gonna try
to present and here's the thing a lot of
people are saying Joe Biden is running
Hillary Clinton's campaign and to a
certain extent he is the difference is
that Joe Biden is not Hillary Clinton
you can run an identical campaign but
the face that you present to the public
makes a huge huge difference
now Biden is also making the case that
president Trump's economy is an
inherited economy it's the Obama economy
now there is some truth to that in the
sense that the stock market did grow
consistently from 2009 to 2016 there is
a bit of lack of truth in the sense that
the economy of the United States was
growing in the slowest recovery in the
history of the United States and then
Trump took office and correlation does
not always equal causation but the
economy has dramatically accelerated
under President Trump in terms of
quarter to quarter GDP growth here is
Joe Biden though saying that that Donald
Trump inherited all the good stuff likes
to take credit for the economy and
economic growth and the low unemployment
numbers but just look at the facts not
the alternative facts
President Trump for her and hurting the
economy from obama-biden administration
that was given to him so this is the
case that Joe Biden is obviously going
to be making now as I say the Democratic
Party platform is way out to the left
Joe Biden simply puts a palatable face
on that Democratic party platform and
it's interesting because President Trump
is really trying desperately not to be
drawn into some of the most politically
polarizing fights so over the weekend
President Trump was asked for example
about Budaj
and his gay marriage and Trump said
there's a lot of people in my own party
who opposed same-sex marriage I'm not
one of those people I think it's great
so there that's Trump trying to defang
that particular that particular argument
from the left he did the same thing on
abortion over the weekend President
Trump suggested that Alabama's abortion
law was effectively too strict the
president tweeted out that he was
strategically against it and I think as
I said last week that there's a case to
be made that the Alabama abortion law
while morally correct is a strategic
mistake in the sense that it is highly
highly unlikely that the Supreme Court
is ready to strike down Roe versus Wade
still the fact that President Trump is
attempting to kind of glide the issue
shows the president Trump is also trying
to run for that moderate middle a
president Trump tweeted this ad he said
as most people know and for those who
would like to know I'm strongly pro-life
with three exceptions rape incest and
protecting the life of the mother the
same position taken by Ronald Reagan
we've come very far in the last two
years with 105 wonderful new federal
judges two great new Supreme Court
justices the Mexico City policy and a
whole new and positive attitude about
the right to life the radical left with
late term abortion and worse is
imploding on this issue we must stick
together and win for life in 2020 if we
are foolish and do not stay united as
one all of our hard-fought gains for
life can and will rapidly disappear
that's president from trying to defame
some of the controversy over abortion
law so President Trump is is trying to
run for the middle and the truth is his
policies are a lot closer to the middle
than Joe Biden's now in a second I will
provide proof that the Democratic Party
is basically just trying to put a
palatable face on radical left ISM while
Trump is actually much more moderate on
policy than I think the typical
Republican we'll get to that in just one
second first let me explain when I'm on
the road I just don't sleep as well the
reason I don't sleep as well is because
I don't
my helix sleep mattress hulex sleep
mattresses are made just for you helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete they match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper a hot sleeper whether you
like a plush or firm bed with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep comm / Ben
take their two minutes sleep quiz it
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10 year warranty and get to try it
out for 100 nights at risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 125 dollars
off at helix sleep calm / Ben that's
helix sleep calm / Ben for up to 125
bucks off your mattress order helix
sleep calm / man I love my helix sleep
mattresses I've expressed my wife and I
ordered it after getting it personalized
for us it is just fantastic I can't wait
to get home today and go to sleep upon
the helix sleep mattress you'll feel the
same helix sleep calm / Ben from - 125
bucks off your mattress order okay so
the other candidate in the Democratic
race who has been heating up is P boo -
judge this has been true for months the
reason that people who to judge has
risen in the polls is because Peabody
judge puts out a moderate face on
radical policy unlike Elizabeth Warren
who seems like a radical and Bernie
Sanders who is openly a radical and
Kamala Harris who is openly a radical P
Buddha judge has attempted to kind of
play it both ways he's the best
politician in this race on the
Democratic side including Joe Biden
I mean he's coming out of nowhere in
South Bend Indiana with effectively no
real record to run on it's pretty
impressive
I mean honestly because if you look at
the polling in hid in South Bend
according to a report that just came out
recently the city of South Bend
Community Survey from 2018 65% of South
Bend residents are dissatisfied with the
maintenance of city streets sidewalks
and infrastructure 51% don't agree they
have an overall feeling of safety in
their neighborhood 64% disagree that the
city has a safe community for everyone
70% don't agree the city has a vibrant
welcoming neighborhood 71% don't agree
the city has a strongly inclusive
economy and 72% don't agree that all
residents are
with education mobility and technology
there's been an uptick in violence as
well in the city of South Bend
nonetheless Peabody dredge is running a
successful campaign for I think probably
the vice presidency why because he is
putting that palatable face on radical
policies and we're gonna deconstruct how
democrats are successful at doing this
so Pete Buddha judge his number one
pitch is that Trump is a bad man Trump
is a very very bad very very bad man so
people to judge first of all is smart
enough to go on Fox News this is a smart
move the reason it's a smart move is
because he understands that there really
is no loss for him if things go badly
for him he just claims that Fox News is
biased against the left and if things go
well for him then he gets to claim that
he has walked into the Lions Den and
emerged unscathed also he rips into Fox
News on Fox News which as a person who's
done this personally is a very good
tactic it's a good tactic so Buddha
judge starts off by by attacking
President Trump as a grotesque human how
would you handle the insults and the
attacks and the tweets and all of that
the tweets are I don't care the fact is
it's a very effective way for him to
reach tens of millions of America it's a
very effective way to command the
attention of the media and well I think
that that you know we need to make sure
that we're changing the channel from
this show that he's created because what
matters and I get it look it's
mesmerizing it's hard for anybody to
look away me too
it is it is the nature of grotesque
things that you can't look away okay so
so I think that his take here is the
smart take which is I don't care about
his tweets President Trump is just a
grotesque figure again orange man bad is
part of the Democratic campaign but he
looks moderate by not fulminating right
Buddha judge his attitudes I'm gonna
smile through this I'm not gonna
fulminate which is the smart thing to do
and then Buddha judge please is the left
by going after Tucker Carlson and Laura
Ingraham on Fox News this is his big win
that he's going to get from the left you
know a lot of folks in my party were
critical of me for even doing this
with Fox News and I've heard that
and I get where that's coming from
especially when you see what goes on
with some of the opinion hosts on this
network I mean when you got Tucker
Carlson saying that immigrants make
America dirty when you've got Laura
Ingraham comparing detention centers
with children and cages to summer camps
summer camps then there is a reason why
anybody has to swallow hard and think
twice before participating in this media
ecosystem
okay so again this is his way of
pandering to the left now the reality is
that what Tucker Carlson actually said
is he said that if you bring in a lot of
people from countries that don't have
the same culture regarding keeping the
streets clean this fruits will be a
little more dirty that's my recollection
of Tucker Carlson's comments I don't
think they're wonderful comments but I
also don't think that that Buddha judge
was being accurate in his
characterization and as far as Laura
Ingraham again I don't think they're
wonderful comments when she is comparing
detention centers to summer camps but my
recollection of that is that what she is
discussing is that people actually are
being treated pretty humanely in
detention centers which is generally a
true story okay nonetheless who to judge
wins some points with the left for
saying all of that sort of stuff
and and because he is coming off as
moderate because of the way he expresses
himself as a moderate he's able to get
away with pushing very extreme policies
this is the democratic plan for 2020 is
to push extraordinarily radical policies
but pretend that you are not radical by
acting moderate so here's people to
judge on abortion he's asked about
whether abortions should be restricted
and he basically says no there should be
no restrictions on abortion but after
all he's saying it a nice tone so I
guess he's a moderate now sees would you
put in place to protect every woman
regardless of her zip codes right to
have an abortion thank you so I believe
that the right of a woman to make her
own decisions about her reproductive
health and about her body is a national
right I believe it's an American freedom
and I believe that should be enjoyed by
now it's funny because a lot of people
are pointing out that he's getting a big
ovation in the Fox News studios that's
because the people who are going to the
Fox News Channel people who judge are
not rabid right-wingers they're fans of
Peabody Judge Bernie Sanders also got
big ovations while he was on Fox News
then Buddha judge was asked specifically
about third trimester abortions and
people who judge defended third
trimester abortions partial-birth
abortion Burson abortion up two points
of birth these are radical positions
that the American public does not hold
hears people who to judge making that
defense saying that you would be okay
with a woman well into the third
trimester deciding to abort her
pregnancy look these hypotheticals are
usually set up in order to provoke a
strong right and it's not hypothetical
there's six thousand women a year who
get abortions in the third it's right
representing less than one percent of
cases pregnancy if it's that late in
your pregnancy that means almost by
definition you've been expecting to
carry it to term we're talking about
women who have perhaps chosen a name
women who have purchased a crib families
that then get the most devastating
medical news of their lifetime okay that
is not true if you look at the
rationales that are generally given for
late term abortion it is not health
problems in the vast majority of cases
according to the Alan Guttmacher
Institute according to people who have
surveyed women who have late term
abortions he sounds moderate and Budaj
is really good at this but because
Wallace was not asking serious follow-up
questions there I mean he started to
write he says there are 6,000
pregnancies and putas judge go well it's
just 1% of cases why are we even worried
about those 1% of cases well let's put
it this way more people are killed every
year in late term abortions 1% of all
cases in America it's about a million
abortions a year so that means that that
1% of a million is what 10,000 cases a
year 10,000 people about two more in
that neighborhood are killed with guns
in the United States not in suicides but
in homicides that's that number of late
term abortions I don't see Peabody Judge
talking about why shootings in the
United States are not a huge problem
nonetheless nonetheless he does come off
as more moderate and this is the picture
of the Democratic Party it's a
personality pitch it is not actually a a
political pitch it's a personality pitch
we'll continue along these lines then
I'll show you what it looks like when
you remove the nice personality and you
get Bernie Sanders because it's the same
it's just that now the nice personality
is gone and you get the irritating guy
from Brooklyn we'll talk about that in
just one second first it's summer the
only thing more annoying than fake
newshour flies and other insects
invading your home here in california we
got this in spades I mean it is brutal
who knows where those flies were last
the fly that just landed on your
hamburger well that could have been
anywhere from another piece of piece of
food to well just think about it or
don't cuz it's disgusting so we would
like to thank our sponsors over at
dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps now they've come up with a
solution for indoor pests the dynatrap
fly light the dynatrap fly light works
day and night to attract and trap flies
fruit flies mosquitoes other pesky
insects it does really work I've got a
couple of them in my kitchen it is just
fantastic
you don't even notice how many flies are
in your kitchen until you realize how
many flies are in your kitchen because
you have a Fly Trap there that prevents
them from getting into your food forget
those disgusting fly strips the dynatrap
fly light looks like a subtle nightlight
that plugs into any indoor outlet I've
been using dynatrap fly light for a
couple of years now actually it's insane
the number of insects that have been
caught than otherwise to be buzzing
around my home annoy me get yours at
dynatrap comm that is Dyn ATR AP calm
that's dynatrap calm enter promo code
daily wire and you receive 15% off any
of their products dynatrap the safe
silent simple solution to household
insect control that is dynatrap calm
safe silent simple it's fantastic go
check them out right now and again use
promo code daily wire you get 15% off
any of their products okay in just a
second we'll finish up with Pete Buddha
judges big move on Fox News and then we
will show you what Buddha judges agenda
looks like when it is expressed by
somebody who is not people who to judge
presentation is everything in
presidential politics we'll get to that
in a second first you have to go over to
daily wear comm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can subscribe to daily wear
comm when you do the rest of the show
live two additional hours every day of
the show which is a fantastic deal you
get to be behind the paywall with me so
you can watch it live like watch it not
just listen to it also you can email me
in the mailbag I will answer your
questions all sorts of goodies we do the
conversation we do daily we're backstage
you get your Sunday special on Saturday
a day early you get extra content with
the Sunday special guests all sorts of
goodies all you have to do is go to
Daley we're calm and when you spend
ninety nine bucks a year which is
cheaper than the monthly and you get the
leftist here's how don't call tumblr you
receive the
of all beverage vessels for just $99 a
year it does make a fantastic Father's
Day gift Father's Day is coming up June
16th so go out and get yourself a
subscription right now to daily wire.com
or get one for Dad I think he'll
appreciate it
also make sure that you subscribe over
YouTube or iTunes leave us a review we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so Buddha judge has a big night and that
big night is predicated on him
expressing very radical ideas in the
most moderate possible fashion so here's
Buddha judge pitching tax hikes openly
three times in about a minute on Fox
News last night when candidates
Democrats go out promising as I think we
should that we're gonna have major
increases in investment in things like
education health and infrastructure we
also got to be willing to say where the
revenue is going to come from and it's
why we really do need to entertain ideas
like I would say a fairer which means
higher marginal income tax rate on those
earning the most a reasonable wealth tax
or something like that to make sure that
people are giving back when they become
enormous ly wealthy okay these are these
are massive tax hikes that he's talking
about a wealth tax is unconstitutional
there's no predicate for Congress being
able to pass a wealth tax it is not
approved by the Constitution only income
taxes are approved by the Constitution
as well as tariffs for example or levies
on the states there are certain specific
types of taxes that are approved by the
Constitution a wealth tax is not one of
them when he suggests that people at the
top of the income bracket have to pay
more in top marginal tax rates that's
insane that's insane
I have paid virtually every tax rate in
the system over the course of my career
I promise you the percentage that I'm
paying now is so much higher than the
percentage that I paid five years ago it
would make your head swim the people who
are at the top of the income brackets
are paying for virtually everything in
this country on a net basis nonetheless
because Buddha judge comes off as
moderate he comes off as moderate he
also tries to downplay his lack of
moderation so Buddha judge was on hugh
hewitt's radio show and hugh hewitt
asked him about Jefferson Jackson
dinners these are these historic
Democrat dinners where people go around
they do fundraising and they've been
named after Thomas Jefferson as well as
Andrew Jackson and Buddha judge
basically disowns Jefferson a little bit
people I think are exaggerating this but
here's what Buddha judge had to say
about Thomas Jefferson Jefferson Jackson
dinners be renamed everywhere because
both were holders of slaves yeah we're
doing that in Indiana I think it's the
right thing to do you know over time you
you develop and evolve on the things you
choose to honor and I think we know
enough especially after you know you
just look at what basically lost the
genocide that happened here Jefferson's
more problematic --it you know there's a
lot to of course admire and thinking in
his philosophy then again
if you plunge into his writings
especially the notes on the state of
Virginia you know that he knew that
slavery was wrong yeah and and yet you
did it okay and then he continued by
suggesting that they maybe ought to
rename all of these things over time you
develop and evolve on things you choose
to honor naming something after someone
confers a lot of Honor Buddha judge
tried to walk that back on Fox News
because he realizes how radical it
sounds to the vast majority of Americans
to to rename things not after Thomas
Jefferson hears Buddha judge making that
case my campaign office is actually on
Jefferson Boulevard look so we're gonna
change the name I'm not planning that
but this is a great example actually of
how the media noise machine on the right
wing takes things out of control so I
mentioned this that you know some
counties are rethinking about some of
our events some of you might have seen
this right basically I said that you
know we're rethinking how we might
democratic functions might name our
event maybe we should name it for a
person who's living maybe we should name
it after a person of color I don't know
next thing you know you would have
thought I'd propose blowing up the
Jefferson Memorial in DC and folks from
Laura Ingraham on this network to
columnist actually in The New York Times
so it's not just a fox thing I just
jumped on that well yeah they jumped on
it because you suggested that maybe we
should actually rename things I mean it
was it was in that context now I'm glad
that the Buddha judges is clarifying all
of that but he didn't I mean we played
the comments for you so you can make
your own decision President Trump was
very angry frankly that Buddha judge was
even getting this attention it's a
problem that the President sees Fox News
as his specific preserve Fox News is not
in fact the president's preserve as Brit
Hume pointed out it is a news network
and they do if they can have an
obligation to have on Democrats to
interview them I will point out that
Buddha judge has expressed interest in
coming on our Sunday special and then as
soon as the left hit him he ran away he
has not gotten back to us he did the
same thing to my friend Dave Rubin he he
was willing to go on Fox News because
Fox News is traditional television but
he's not willing to go on with anybody
who might have a longer form
conversation with him in the absence of
a crowd I think in any case President
Trump tweeted out hard to believe that
Fox News is wasting airtime on mayor
Pete as Chris Wallace likes to call him
Fox is moving more and more to the
losing wrong side and covering the Dems
they got dumped from the Democrats
boring debate and they
one in they forgot the people who got
them there Chris Wallace actually said I
actually think whether you like his
opinions are not mayor Pete has a lot of
substance fascinating biography G he
never speaks well of me I like Mike
Wallace better and Alfred you Newman
will never be President well first of
all the Alfred E Newman tag on mayor
Pete is pretty great but beyond that you
know Trump is evincing and evidencing he
is he's evidencing a fair bit of
disquiet here and if he's really
confident in this election advice to
President Trump just stop just stop
because this is all gonna play out
Democrats are gonna savage each other
all you have to do is sit off to the
side you don't need to comment every
time you see somebody on the TV who's
ripping into all you're doing is
elevating Pete Budi judge now as I've
been saying moody judge presents an
attractive face for Democratic
radicalism in those clips you heard him
effectively argue in favor of late term
abortion including up - point of birth
in favor of massive wealth tax increases
him attacking other news networks which
is last I heard when President Trump did
it all of a sudden it was an attack on
the press when when Buddha judge does it
then it's just him being brave but when
you strip away the nice face what you
end up with here is Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders makes exactly the same
points the people who judge does on most
of these topics here's Bernie Sanders
over the weekend talking about abortion
on NBC News with Bob go Barney talk do
you believe there should be any
restrictions on abortion in in law I
think that that is a decision that is
being made that should be made by the
woman in her position and I think many
of you know what people are doing this
sadly is creating a political issue out
of a medical issue so the decision about
women should be able to control their
own body and those decisions are made by
a doctor so again this is Bernie Sanders
repeating the same road talking points
but the no:1 sound is attractive coming
from Bernie Sanders because he's not as
interactive a candidate Bernie Sanders
by the way over the weekend also
suggested that baseball players make too
much money you know when folks on the
right say that folks on the left sound
like economic fascist like they want to
control every aspect of your economic
life this would be the reason why listen
to how Bernie Sanders describes baseball
payer baseball players being paid it's
pretty amazing
nation that can provide contracts to
baseball players for hundreds of
millions of dollars don't tell me we
cannot pay teachers in this country the
kind of wages and salaries they deserve
the government does not pay baseball
players okay and the government is not
the nation we pay baseball players
because we are willing when teachers can
draw 40,000 paying customers then they
will get paid like baseball players
that's not the way this works
there are lots and lots of teachers who
are capable of teaching third grade
they're only a couple of people on
planet earth or capable of hitting a 100
mile per hour baseball and entertaining
millions of people that doesn't mean
that on a social level what is more
valuable our baseball players than
teachers it means that there is a market
for baseball players in a way there is
not for teachers and that if you want to
get paid like a baseball player you have
to be one of a couple hundred most elite
people on planet earth at this
particular job I mean I guess maybe
teachers should just go write a book
like Bernie Sanders write Bernie Sanders
says that he's written a best-selling
book and this means that he deserves the
wealth that he has earned from his books
I guess those teachers maybe she'd just
go write a book again when you strip
away the attractive facade of the people
judges what you end up with is Bernie
Sanders now Bernie Senators also did an
interview over the weekend about his
foreign policy that is extraordinarily
radical and frightening and reminds us
why Democrats should not be in charge of
foreign policy that when Barack Obama
left office the world was on fire in a
lot of ways that the Arab Spring was a
giant fail that the former president of
the United States should pallets of cash
to Iran the former president of the
United States let Russia walk all over
him and now Bernie Sanders is promoting
that exact same sort of foreign policy
he said I plead guilty boo throughout my
adult life doing everything that I can
to prevent war and destruction really
everything he could to prevent more
instruction like he supported the
Communists in Nicaragua he honeymooned
in the Soviet Union I'm pretty sure he
didn't do everything he could to avoid
war and destruction he said I'm very
proud that in my small city we
established two sister city programs
which I believe honestly are still going
on today one with Yaroslavl a city in
Russia the other with the city Puerto
Cabezas in Nicaragua and I happen to
believe cultural exchanges and student
exchanges are a very important tool to
try to bring people together and avoid
Wars and also I helped lead the
opposition to the war in Iraq etc etc
and he says that he was asked by the New
York Times that that Bernie attended a
rally in Managua and a wire report at
the time said there were anti-american
chants from the crowd and Bernie
answered the United States was actively
supporting the Contras to overthrow the
government so there was anti-american
sentiment I remember that I remember
that event very clearly he said they
were fighting against American he said
are you shocked to learn there was
anti-american sentiment in other words
he sided with the communist government
of Nicaragua and was not upset when
people were chanting anti-american
things that is the foreign policy of
Bernie Sanders unfortunately that's the
foreign policy of a large swath of the
Democratic Party today there's been a
lot of talk about quote unquote nut
picking meaning finding nuts in the
Democratic Party and talking about them
the fact is the mainstream Democratic
Party has moved significantly to the
left over time Bernie Sanders is now
considered a thought leader in the
Democratic Party where he was considered
a kook back in the 1980s even mainstream
Democrats are pushing radical policies
Amy Klobuchar who is considered a more
moderate to right leaning Democrat was
asked about abortion over the weekend by
Chris Wallace and she said she didn't
want any abortion restrictions are you
okay with abortions after 24 weeks
to protect the life in the health of the
mother that is exactly what the Supreme
Court ruling says and I am ok with that
to protect the life and health of the
mother health of the mother means that
for any reason effectively you can get
an abortion Kirsten Gillibrand also
running for presidents a sitting senator
from New York she was asked about
immigration detention she said I would
detain no one should have no detentions
at the border this is the Democratic
Party and the Democratic Party is trying
to shield their own radicalism by
putting out Joe Biden was just sort of
seen as this doddering old nice guy and
Peabody dredge who's seen as a a
moderate because he wears a tie but he
doesn't wear a jacket and because he's a
friendly face but Kirsten Gillibrand is
again a mainstream Democrat here she is
saying she would not detain anyone ever
do you then support something like
Senator Graham has proposed which would
you mentioned family separation to stop
what the administration has used as a
justification for that they have said
look legally were restricted to only
keeping
people in detention together for 20 days
you can't move in detention at all but
you oppose even what the Obama
administration did in terms of keeping
families together or keeping them
together for a longer period of time in
detention
I wouldn't as president the United
States I wouldn't use the detention
system at all at all at all okay that is
a mainstream Democrat running for
president talking about that Kamala
Harris over the weekend came out and
said that she wants to find companies
that pay men more than women not on the
basis of experience not on the basis of
different jobs if just plainly on
average men are paid more than women
even if women take time off from the
workforce have different jobs work fewer
hours she wants to find those companies
that's the heart and soul of the
Democratic Party at this point it's
gonna be up to President Trump to number
one provide a more palatable face first
policies and number two to point out
that no matter how friendly these
Democrats may appear the people who
judges in the Joe Biden's behind the the
smiling facade lurks the same agenda as
Kirsten Gillibrand and Kamala Harris and
Bernie Sanders that is the task for the
President of the United States if he
wishes to win reelection it is indeed
that simple okay time for some things I
like and then we'll get to some things
that I hate so things that I like so
Mark Levin has a new book out this week
I've been reading it over the weekend
it's really fun it's called on freedom
of the press by fun I mean that it's an
easy read that tells you a lot about the
history of the press in the United
States it's already number one at Amazon
blowing up on the charts so go check out
mark levins a new book I think it only
comes out in a couple of days but you
can pre-order it right now on freedom of
the press marks a good friend and a
wonderful dude and a great thinker go
check out on freedom of the press right
now other things that I likes I have to
say congratulations to not only
everybody who graduated over the weekend
and is graduating over the coming few
weeks cuz we have a lot of college
students law students who listen to the
program my brother-in-law graduated from
University of Virginia law school
yesterday so congratulations to Jacob
but to all grads I want to say
congratulations because big weekend for
you other things that I like so Jim
Carrey put out a cartoon that I think is
actually quite wonderful he put out a
cartoon and it's and said I think if
you're going to terminate a pregnancy it
should be done sometime before the fetus
becomes governor of Alabama his painting
is of what appears to be a late term
abortion of governor KIV it's her face
and her brains are being sucked into
some sort of tube now this is the reason
that I put this in things I like is
because it does demonstrate full scale
how many pro-abortion activists feel
they are fine with the procedure of
abortion there's a pretty accurate
depiction of what a Dean of what am a
D&E looks like isolation and extraction
or adoration or or GNC actually
basically the tube here is sucking out
the brains of governor ki by the way no
suspension on Twitter nothing right
really not like social media is not
cracking down on this at all so that's
but it has by the way almost a hundred
thousand likes at this point the murder
of Kay Ivey the sitting governor of the
state of Alabama so number one Democrats
don't keep many Democrats not all many
Democrats don't care about the brutality
of the procedure even if they fully
understand it as this painting seems to
and number two if they could they would
murder everyone who they disagree with
which is a pretty amazing amazing thing
from Jim Carrey so thanks to Jim Carrey
for at least his honesty okay other
things that I like today so this could
be both in things I like and things I
hate the time has come for a game of
Thrones finale review so if you have not
yet seen the Game of Thrones finale then
you're gonna want to skip the next few
minutes of the program because I'm going
to go into great detail and that means
that we are going to have to we are
going to have to spoil some things okay
so let's talk about what just happened
the episode starts John is watching as
as gray one basically execute people and
then John is told by so Tyrion gets
imprisoned and John does nothing the
biggest problem with this season of Game
of Thrones and the last season actually
is that John becomes a non-factor John
is basically an extra in this season
he's turned into a whiny twerp so he
goes around the season basically
lovesick for Dany who's an by the way he
watches her nuke a million people and
he's still spending half the episode
going oh she's my queen she's Michael
she just nuked a million people dude a
million like I have seen you try to take
up arms to go with Rob and you were
about to leave I've seen you go defend
the the wildlings from the north instead
of letting them all get killed
you let a battle in Winterfell against
Ramsay Bolton I mean like
and yet when it comes to Danny suddenly
it's cool for her to like nuke the
entire city of King's Landing that's but
you don't draw a line there so John is
basically whiny he sees it Tyrion who's
screwed everything up Terrance has Tim
you need to take out Danny why well
because you are the one true heir and
now the entire series has been set up to
this point that John is the true heir
and it should matter that he is the true
heir and not only that John has to be
active because he is the hero of the
story so John goes he sees Danny all
this is fine Danny is is going crazy and
she gives the full-on fascist slash
communist answer which is in the pursuit
of utopia I get to kill whoever I want
which is something that fascists have
said many many times right this is the
this is the Milton Friedman description
the Frederick Hayek description of
fascism and socialism and John's like
okay well you're hot and you're my aunt
but not enough and he kills her okay so
once John kills her this is where things
begin to go wildly wrong so what has to
happen at that point is that John then
has to take the throne at least
temporarily the dragon is right there
for some reason the dragon is pissed off
at the throne nobody knows why dragon
just like you know what this throne
right here this mf'er I'm taking out the
throne and they just blow torches the
throne the dragon like well that's weird
don't know why the dragon is that doing
that and the dragon won't attack John
obviously because he's Targaryen but the
question is what happens next because
the next thing you see you flash-forward
to three weeks later and John is in
prison this makes no sense
grey worm has just executed half the
city and great you think great woman's
not gonna run in and try to kill John
like right then that instant the dragon
has already flown away with Danny's body
there's nothing to stop him why doesn't
just run in and spear John through the
chest that's what you would expect to
happen and even that would have made a
certain amount of sense if Sansa had
then arrived and fought grey worm or
something but instead we just fast
forward to three weeks later and
everybody she's having a meetin for no
reason so here I'll tell you what should
it happened after I tell you what does
happen we've finished reviewing the
episode so the so John ends up in prison
antarians is in prison too and then
suddenly were three weeks later and
Tyrion is brought forth and there's this
council and the council has basically
Sansa Stark and all of her family
members raised the Tully's who you'll
recall are
relatives of her mother and it is the
Aaron's who are also relatives of her
mother so it's like her mom's entire
family is now the only powerful people
in Westeros and Tyrion comes out and
great warmth shows up and great ones
like well we're not gonna let John go we
want to execute him and it sounds like
well if you execute him we're gonna go
to war with you and their agreement is
that we are going to send John north to
the wall hey this is the problem if John
wanted to take the crown and then
abdicate and say listen I don't want any
part of this I've been too messed up by
this like Frodo at the end of Lord of
the Rings I got to go north of the wall
I'm not interested that would make some
sense he is the rightful heir instead
he's getting negotiated over by grey
worm who is the best a secondary
character and Sansa Stark for who ends
up ruling the North Burton for note okay
so we'll get to what should have
happened as I say in a second so there's
this council and the council is while
sitting there and they're like oh who
should we make the king and the only
funny moments of this by the way is when
Sam proposes a democracy and then all of
the words like ha ha ha we have an
electoral college here that was pretty
great I will admit because my great fear
was that it was gonna be like let all
the people vote listen in real life I'm
a big fan of all the people voting in
fantasy fiction how anticlimactic would
it be if they're like we have to let all
the people vote and then all the people
vote for like whoever's the reality TV
star of the day but they who do they
decide on so here's what they don't
decide on they don't decide on Sansa
who's sitting right there happens to be
queen of the North also is the
legitimate heir to Jon right Jon is the
rightful king if jon is not the king who
is the legitimate heir to Jon
well she presumably as Queen of the
north would be because bran has declared
himself unavailable for this job right
bran goes back to Winterfell
at some point earlier and he's the
rightful heir he's like I don't want it
I'm not interested in I'm not interested
in it but it's not gonna go to Sansa
Tyrion is like you know everything is
built around stories everything is built
yet we need a story to sell to the
people and who has a better story than
bran and I'm sitting there going
everyone every single person who is
sitting there including Edmund Tully has
a better story than bran brand story is
he was thrown out of a tower and then
people sledded it around and sledded him
around for 7 seasons and now he's here
get to brand in a second so everybody on
the council like yeah you know what
great idea let's make it brand let's
make it the most useless person in all
seven seasons of Game of Thrones to this
point that guy let's make it him except
for Sansa and Sansa says yeah and not
into it
number one dude can't have kids number
two no just no not gonna do that I'm
going independent my favorite part of
this is that Asha Greyjoy is sitting
right there and she's got to be thinking
to herself why didn't I do that like how
does she get out of this but I don't get
out of this how is that a real thing and
everybody else is yeah let's make it
brand for no reason for no reason at all
not Arya who has killed the night king
learn to shape-shift is a member of the
stark family who is not the three-eyed
Raven not her not Santa who runs a
kingdom up north not John who is still
sitting in prison and is the only true
heir to the throne right he's the only
Targaryen and he's a stark he's the only
heir to the throne no we're gonna banish
John to the north for no reason at all
and then I guess the idea was that he
has to be banished to the north because
they made a deal with with the unsullied
except the unsullied believe right the
unsullied go to NARTH so at that point
wouldn't you see sonzai going you know
who'd be the true king right now that
guy nope Sons is like you know what
sorry I couldn't do anything about you
being banished to the north where I'm
the queen and she could just be like
yeah you know John you could you could
like be on the throne like that would be
a thing nope they banished him to the
north so Arya goes and plays Columbus
colonizer Arya who's I guess now our
favorite character she's bringing
Western Westeros Westeros II
civilization to unknown lands and then
you get and then you get bran sitting
there how useless is bran in his first
council meeting his advisors are sitting
around talking about okay we need a
sewage system we also need to rebuild
our military and also we need to rebuild
our Navy and bran is like okay you guys
all do that I'm gonna go over here and
smoke some weed basically whatever
happened that dragon I don't know I'm
gonna go over here and ward got a fly
like a bird man just like at the Battle
of Winterfell got a fly like a useless
person so here is what should have
happened what should have happened you
could even have bran be king what should
have happened is that after John kills
Daenerys before the dragon picks up
Danny's body and leaves John should have
hopped onto the back of the dragon the
unsullied come try
charging up through the door they're
about to kill John except that John is
now on top of the greatest telling
machine in the history of Westeros and
he says any any and and then you fade to
black because it is obvious that John is
now the king or John is on top of the
dragon and then you hear a horn from
outside because remember Varys sends his
little birds all over to let everyone
know that John is the actual heir to the
throne everyone is supposed to know this
already
Sansa arrives from the north now the
unsullied are trapped in the middle and
they just surrender and then John says
to sonzai and bran and Tyrion I can't do
this I'm out you know I had to kill this
woman that I loved and I've been to
ruined by all of this I need to go north
and find my dog and then he gives it to
bran then you have the same counsel seen
all that time the problem is by robbing
John of his agency it makes it makes him
a pathetic character he's a loser who
has to kill the only woman he's
interested in who happens to be his aunt
and then he gets imprisoned by a eunuch
and then he gets sent against his will
back to the north of the wall none of
that makes any sense at all okay final
take on this final take on this um I
will say I have an alternative theory
not a reason to like this but here's my
alternative theory it's my Jar Jar Binks
as a Cynthia hey my theory is that bran
is the most evil person in Westeros
because it turns out the brand can see
the future there's a scene at the at the
council meeting where Heath where there
like bran do you want to be the king and
brands like why do you think I came all
this way in other words I knew it was
gonna happen the whole time okay so
let's assume he knew it was gonna happen
the whole time here are the things that
bran did he's a bad guy
if brand knew what was gonna happen the
whole time he is a bad bad man so what
what are all the things one he abandons
Rick on you remember he had a brother
named Rick on and he could go back with
Rick on to Winterfell
instead he's like you know what not
interested out Rick on goes back Rick on
gets killed he's like I'm gonna take
these two people you know and my two
friends here we're gonna go north of the
wall because I'm having these weird
visions okay he goes in the north of the
wall he gets dragged around on a sled
gets one of them killed gets Hodor
killed and then treats the the woman
who's carrying him around I can't
remember her name Mira he treats her
like garbage to the point where she's
like why are you treating me badly he's
like I'm not brown
I'm the three-eyed Raven unless I decide
to become king in which case I'm brown
again he gets rid of her Madeline
Winterfell happens he does nothing zero
things does he do during the Battle of
Winterfell he's like I'm gonna sit here
in my chair not gonna do anything I'm
just gonna sit here and am I gonna warg
into one of the Dragons nope am I gonna
tell fee on what to do so he can save
his life nope imma be like Theon
you're a good man go charge at that guy
uselessly and get stabbed
well done bran and Theon's like well you
could do somethings like nope I'm
turning into birds for no reason just
Birds man got a flat ik bird so prey
bran is totally useless during the
Battle of Winterfell
he tells John about his lineage for no
reason for no reason imagine he doesn't
tell John about his lineage John marries
Dany happily ever after right but he
tells John about his lineage so now John
knows his lineage but he doesn't tell
John that Danny's gonna go crazy which
apparently he already knows or at least
has a good sense of which would have
been helpful before a million people
were burned to death in King's Landing
he then accepts the crown but after
accepting the crown he doesn't accept
the crown ago and you know what the true
heir is John John is the king and said
he's like I'm the king now okay I guess
I'll stick with the steel John goes
north he lets his sister go independent
right he's like okay well Sansa she's
gonna go independent that's fine she
gets to take the north totally cool Asha
Greyjoy you stay in you ain't going
nowhere sister and then finally he lets
the council handle the sewage and
military problems while he puffs the
magic dragon so bran is actually an evil
genius this is Mike my theory he's like
a Sith Lord
he's an evil genius he let the knight
King do what he wanted to do for several
seasons so the knight king would take
out two dragons making it possible for
him to take the crown after the third
dragon couldn't burn John so they said
it was disapointing then again all of it
would have been okay if they had let
John be the character that he was the
first few seasons which is a guy who
reluctantly is forced into a position of
leadership but having John be imprisoned
by people is so dumb it's so dumb and I
guess tyrion gets what he deserves
sort of I Santa is the only person
really by the way at the end of the if
there were another season of Game of
Thrones you know who becomes the queen
of all of all Westeros right Sansa
because bran when he dies who
the who's the only legitimate heir Sansa
who also happens to be to have the only
independent army and all of whose
relatives sit on that Council and
happens to be married to the hand of the
king right she's still married to Tyrion
so there's that all right so this was
the thing I like or thing I hate it was
mostly a thing that I was kind of pissed
about you know overall the series is
still great I'm just angry that in the
end they robbed the only hero who is
left of his agency in the show it every
the only thing that he does that his
worthwhile is he kills Dany which is sad
but then he proceeds to become a loser
who sent back north of the wall the way
that he was when he was a kid which is
irritating okay so that counts as I
think both things I like and things I
hate I think we'll skip the rest because
that was about a 1-hour recapitulation
of Game of Thrones we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours I
plan on spending all of them talking
Game of Thrones in fact this week
nothing but Game of Thrones or John wick
three talk I don't know I'm getting
bored with with I'm getting bored with
with people to judge on Fox News I'm not
sure about you guys but I'd rather talk
Game of Thrones and we'll see you here
later today i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today the Democrats have once again
proven that they are a radical anti
science cult which we already knew but
now we have more evidence of that with
the passage of a bill that would if it
became law among other things force
women's sports teams to allow men so
we'll discuss that also mayor Pete is
supposed to be this moderate reasonable
Democrat but why is he then advocating
for abortion in the third trimester is
that moderate and reasonable now and the
Democrat Party will talk about that and
other things today on the Matt Walsh
show